you mentioned Herzog
just to uh Venture down this road of
death and fear and so on there's been a
few Mad Men like you in this world
uh he's documented a couple of them uh
what lessons do you draw from Grizzly
Man or into the wild those kinds of
stories I were you ever afraid that you
would be one of those stories oh yeah I
actually think that that's in Mother of
God where I said I almost until into the
wild did myself like I I went out there
and really I got so lost and so
destroyed that I said this this is this
is going to be the next one you know
this is gonna be the next story of some
idiot kid from New York who went to the
Amazon thinking he was Percy Fawcett and
then vanished because if you if you do
vanish out there your body's going to be
consumed in a matter of days like like
two you know if we see if we see an
animal dead on a trail it's you got dung
beetles and and fly larva and vultures
and there's a whole pecking order you
know you get the black vultures the
yellow vultures the king vulture they
all come in that thing is picked clean
in a couple of days what would be the
creature that eats most of you in that
situation probably the vultures probably
the vultures and the and the maggots
it's it's really quick it's really
really quick like like like you even as
far as like you can't leave food out you
know like if you have like a piece of
chicken you say oh I'll eat it in the
morning you leave it out you can't do
that it's not it's not good by morning
Grizzly Man for example like what
because that's a beautiful story it's
both comical and genius and especially
the way Herzog tells it well first of do
you like the way you told the story do
you like hersa I do I love Herzog and I
love his his documentary the burden of
Dreams which is which is in the Amazon
not very far from where I work and the
the sheer Madness that you see this man
undergoing of just trying to recreate
hauling a boat over a mountain
um is is is wild and and the you know
the the extras that he hired to be to
play the natives are are the I think
they're matcha ganga tribesmen and
they're just they just look like all the
guys that I hang out with and it's like
you know they're doing all this stuff in
the jungle that months and months and
months and you can just see him
deteriorating with Madness because the
jungle you know your boat you know how
many times I've tied up a boat to the
side of the river this just happened
like a year and a half ago I tied up
through a lot through covet I pretty
much just lived in the jungle for a
while and there was nobody there and
there was no support and I tied up my
boat and the rain is just hammering like
like like the universe is trying to rip
the Earth in half the rain is just going
and the river's rising and I tied up the
boat
but then you go to sleep and you got to
wake up every two hours to go check the
boat and the boat is thrashing back and
forth and so all night every two hours
I'd wake up barefoot in driving rain
like you know golf ball raindrops and
just go down check the boat and then by
morning I was like I fell asleep woke up
checked the boat and then I was like I'm
just gonna go make coffee I was so done
I was so like at the end of my rope
every time bailing the boat out and
stuff
and then we got 15 minutes of heavy rain
that filled the boat sanket
so now I'm stuck up River with no boat
and it's like that type of thing where
it's like no matter how hard you try the
jungle's just like listen
you ain't you're nothing you are nothing
and so it's that constant reminder and
so Herzog really threw himself into that
in that film and uh it's it's brilliant
to watch what do you think he meant by
the line that you include in your book
it's a land that God if he exists has
created in anger
said in German accent yeah overwhelming
and Collective murder
um
so that's that's
so he didn't really appreciate the
beauty of the of the murder I think he
appreciated it but to him it was very
dark you know I think he saw the
darkness in it and that's there it sure
is as soon as you do Ayahuasca you that
door opens and you see the darkness
because it brings you right into the
jungle like the the heart of it but I
think that for him it it is I think that
darkness is something that he Embraces
and that he loves there's another film
of his and I don't know if this is
accurate but my memory has it that
there's a penguin and I think it's in
Antarctica and the Penguins going in the
wrong direction away from the ocean yeah
and I feel like he goes on this
monologue about how like he's just had
enough yeah he's you know this one
penguin is just marching towards you
know yeah well he his because I remember
that clip from that uh documentary
and what Werner says is that the penguin
is deranged yes he's lost his mind and I
took offense to that yeah because maybe
that's a brave Explorer like how do you
know there's not some a lot more going
on like
it could be a love story those penguins
get super attached maybe his mate was
over there and he had to go find her
like or it's a lost mate and he last
time he saw her was going in that
direction exactly so this is like the
great Explorer they we we assume animals
are like the average of the bell curve
like every animal we interact with is
just the average but they're special
ones just like they're special humans
yeah that could be a special penguin ah
it could have been and I had the same
thought where I was like I was like he's
I I found it beautiful how he
interpreted it what I took away from
that was I found that born of herzog's
monologue there was was brilliantly dark
and also comedic
but but maybe irrelevant biologically
speaking towards penguins like you know
um which which happens a lot with
animals I find like there's so many
times where I'll find people be like do
you think that animals can show
compassion and you hear like a bunch of
people that have never left the pavement
talking about like wow this this one
animal helped another and it's like it's
like go ask Jane Goodall if animals can
show compassion go go talk to anybody
that works on a daily basis with animals
and they'll and so like to me there's a
there's always a little bit of
frustration in hearing people sort of
like pleasantly surprised that animals
aren't just you know these you know
these automatons of you know just just
what's the word like um like programmed
you know nothingness